emily is in Birmingham hey Emily welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi thanks Dave
we'll add my husband and my husband and
I are having a little disagreement I
hope and you can help us out okay I
recently came into a little bit of
inheritance after losing with my
grandparents for the past year and I'm
Shirley and thank you we have two debts
one being our mortgage and then the
second being our car and my husband
wants and feels that the money should go
towards the car and I am just viewing it
as a little bit more sentimental and
wanting it to go towards something a
little bit more sentimental I'm
wondering is that incorrect that kind of
you the money is kind of like a final
gift and should I just kind of take away
the emotions and just go towards that so
you want to buy something with it well
yes like I'm meeting a new suite of
appliances all mine have kind of been
around for way too long and I'm hardly
working in the first place so and my
grandmother's the one that taught me how
to cook so for me that would be kind of
a more final gift I guess I would say
but my husband is like hey if we have
the extra money let's put it towards the
car and get that paid down okay how much
money is involved just under 9 grand
well I analyze these things through
sentimental lens as well and the way I
would ask myself this is okay grandma
was obviously good with her money does
she left her grandkid and kids 9,000
bucks
okay so grandma was sitting in heaven
looking at her grandbaby what makes her
smile because her granddaughter did this
with the money I'm not thinking a
dishwasher does that now I get the tie
into she taught you to cook I might take
a thousand dollars and buy
some cooking utensils so that every time
I use that set of pots and pans or
knives or whatever that I thought of
grandma and I put the rest of it on the
car but I think grandma probably was
somebody that hated debt and she might
be smiling if you paid off the debt I
got to agree with your husband okay
but it's not I'm not doing that through
the lens of I'm calling your sentiments
silly I'm just saying I'm just saying
your sentiment you couldn't actually use
that to try to say okay this you know
the character of this woman she was a
frugal person a saving person she was
careful with their money my guess is she
hated debt does that sound familiar I
mean
oh yes yes they paid off all that now
and real estate and made it pretty much
as their retirement funds yeah so I mean
I think she'd be smiling if you paid off
your car but also things should be
smiling if you've spent you know a grand
on some stuff to use in the kitchen I
get that let's balance this out a little
bit how much do you owe on the car see
we still have but I think 24 to $25,000
sauce on the cars mm-hmm
what's your household I wouldn't pay it
off there just don't get in it what's
your household income right under six
figures a year okay all right well it's
all going to get taken care of pretty
soon anyway so more than anything it's
just an emotional discussion I don't I
mean yeah as long as you don't well I
you know what would Dave and sharing
ramsey do we would look at it through
the lens of what is wise and that would
also be pleasing to grandma and so I
probably would buy you know I'd probably
say Sharon let's go get a really high
end amazing set of cooking pots and pans
and knobs or whatever drop a grand on it
I don't know something like that and
then let's throw the rest of it at this
in honor of grandmother because I think
she'd be smiling about both things I
think you're you know you're honoring
her life her tradition the way she
thought and believed
and that is sentiment and that's a
reasonable sentiment so you do whatever
you want that's just the way I think
through it and now you've got an added
argument a third idea thrown on the
table this is the Dave Ramsey show